what's up guys
bang bang he just flicked me in the head
fact lunch money time when wall street's
trying to get rich russell that's just
trying to get her lunch money right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
plena evilova marinova pompliano
aka pimp she's got red on breaking the
dress code let's go
we do not need that nickname to stick
it's pomp and pimp
it's perfect we don't need that guys
facts don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
they've got three products you can buy
and sell crypto you can deposit crypto
and take out a us dollar loan
or my favorite product you can get up to
8.6
interest in an interest bearing account
there's risk go do your research i'm an
investor in the company
and a big time user a very happy user
get money get paid go
use block five block five dot com slash
lunch money
i did it all in less than 50 seconds
what's up with anti-trust world guys
today
is day the moment of truth and i'm not
talking about
anything but you're going to lose your
bet you're going to lose the best second
hold on let's remind the people the bet
was
that jeff bezos would go to this hearing
i
said in anything but a suit and tie he
said in a suit and tie
but small wrinkle it's not going to be
in person it's going to be over
zoom do you not think that bezos is
going to roll
up in his t-shirt and jeans looking all
cool
sorry i was yawning because there's no
way that's going to happen
impossible he's going to wear a seat in
time all right we'll see
that's fine what's going on with the
anti-trust what is the hearing the heads
of four of the largest tech companies in
the world are scheduled to sit before
the house judiciary committee today
for what is expected to be the
blockbuster event of the summer you know
it's a sad world when this is the
blockbuster event
during a pandemic and a recession this
is what we were worried about jeff bezos
tim
cook mark zuckerberg and tsundar pichei
are all gonna do this uh it's over zoom
it's gonna be super weird
i don't think it's gonna be anywhere
near as intense as it normally would be
because it's remote over zoom
all the politicians are gonna be like
wait can you see me or am i on
mute well and also like they just had uh
a g
bar uh in front of the attorney general
bar
in front of a hearing in person so i
don't understand why they can't have
these people come in person
uh they all have private jets like they
just fly there um
and ultimately there's incredible irony
i just tweeted it before we started this
which is that uh the u.s government
which is the greatest monopoly in the
world
uh is going to be grilling entrepreneurs
about monopolies like
it's just so hypocritical i can't wait
let me tell you how exciting dinner
at our house is last night we ate dinner
quietly
with the laptop open reading uh the
comments that
jeff bezos will say opening remarks
opening remarks it's a fantastic piece i
highly suggest reading it
i wouldn't have written it that way but
that's just me but
so many things he starts with his mom's
experience i would have ended it with
his mom's experience it's a nice little
circle
he he's all over the place i don't like
it guys disagree
okay he starts with his family and he
ends with us but it is
interesting how all these guys are
trying to like
how they're trying to position
themselves so jeff bezos is all about
this is
the quintessential american company i
started from nothing here's what i've
built
then there's facebook uh zuck is trying
to play on the angle of we're an
all-american company trying to go again
like hard at uh tick tock which is
you know chinese ties so it's very
interesting what's going on with
uh mackenzie scott aka mackenzie
bezos x mackenzie bezos mackenzie scott
yeah you better not leave me i'ma change
to pim
real quick
mackenzie scott was the former wife of
jeff bezos jeff bezos handed her 30
billion dollars
and jeff bezos is still the richest guy
in the world i don't care but you know
what she's done with that
35 billion dollars she's made so far a
1.7 billion dollar donation
across 116 organizations false
what this isn't with the 30 billion
dollars that jeff bezos gave her
oh i think she's made it another like 36
billion
dollars off the stock and uh
yeah he gave her a 4 stake that was
worth about 35 billion at the time
it's currently estimated to be worth
almost 60 billion
worth what do you every single dollar of
her net worth is from the stock that
jeff bezos i don't think so i think
she's a very successful
she was a very successful writer and
novelist do you think that she made more
than 10 million dollars as a writer and
obviously absolutely
okay okay so by the way that's fine
but the 1.7 billion dollars that she's
giving literally this happened like last
year she got 30 billion
35 billion dollars so she's gained she's
almost doubled that
uh net worth to 60 billion and she's
only giving away 1.7 billion by the way
i'm not giving out 1.7 billion nobody
here is giving out 1.7 billion
so like who cares how much she gained
but it's not
1.7 billion that bezos uh had to give
her
it's 1.7 billion 1.7 billion dollars
across
116 organizations focused on one of nine
areas of need i guess that she's
identified
including racial equity lgbtq plus
equity functional democracy and climate
change
what is functional democracy uh well i
should just be democracy
i was gonna ask what's the plus in lgbtq
plus there's a lot okay i'll just leave
it at that i don't
i will research i will i will uh educate
you after this
all right and then also the na uh naacp
legal defense and education fund the
obama foundation the george w
bush presidential center uh rain the
european climate foundation
part of what i like about i looked
through the list yesterday uh she's very
uh nonpartisan in it
so like literally she's giving to the
george w bush foundation
into the obama um foundation and and
just
do we know what the george w bush
presidential center is
he's in texas yeah and it's like the
whole thing is just
i've never met her right uh everything
i've read online
and things like this like she seems like
a pretty cool person and
genuinely wants to make a difference and
now she's got 60 billion dollars and
she's probably gonna have an impact
so one story i remember and correct me
if i'm wrong i may be misremembering it
but it was something along these lines
a few years ago when jeff bezos was
getting attacked in
the comment sections of a lot of news
articles
mackenzie would step in and defend jeff
in the comment section it was amazing it
was like all over um
and she would also uh i think she did it
in the amazon comments as well i don't
know
super interesting but i got a problem
what's your problem why aren't you
defending me which of the trolls on
twitter because i am the troll
okay that's pretty good actually uh
what's going on facebook
all right so to beat tick tock facebook
is allegedly throwing money at creators
to try to lure
them on to facebook and instagram what
do you think about that
non-story they're all doing it it's just
who wants to admit it
tick-tock is paying creators facebook is
paying creators
instagram which is owned by facebook is
paying creators uh
other people are being paid twitch mixer
every platform that ken is paying the
creators it's all about do you have the
best creators
and of course if facebook and
tick tock are gonna get in this like
basically pissing match
on who gets the best talent well
you can sit there all day long and be
like oh my camera is better or oh we
have more people or oh
our algorithms engagement will get you
more fam all that
at the end of the day people say are you
going to pay me or not right and you see
this in
college sports where people get paid to
go places you see this with creators
getting paid to go on a certain platform
also i don't know if you saw but some of
the tick tock stars are going to be
leaving tick tock
and they're going to be going to triller
which is how is that
it's a la based uh short form video
that's a competitor to tick tock and
they're claiming that they're gonna do
it
uh josh richards and a couple of others
are gonna leave tick tock and go to
triller
mainly because of the data privacy
issues my guess is
it's an egotistical thing in terms of
i've got a big enough audience if i
leave i can bring them with me
they may be right or they may not and
two i wouldn't be surprised if chiller
gave them equity
i do it does not matter unless charlie
demilio addison ray
and dixie leave tick tock to do that i i
just
all those little ones just richard
joshua i don't even know what i think he
has 20 million followers
nothing charlie has like 80. he's got
more than dixie does i think come on
all right but here is it isn't it good
that i i know i'm in the
know of all of these these little kids
running around on the internet it's
really creepy
here's a small wrinkle in the facebook
tick tock drama
tick tock ceo kevin meyer is accusing
facebook of using patriotism
as an unfair way to attack the
chinese-owned consumer app
because in his opening remarks zuck
calls facebook
as being a proudly american company
so uh kevin
meyer mayor of tick tock at a tick tock
welcome competition we think fair
competition
competition makes us all better but
let's focus our energies on
fair and open competition in service of
our community
consumers rather than maligning attacks
by our competitor namely facebook
disguised as patriotism and designed to
put an end to our very presence in the
us
they are salty just like you by the way
he's just saying the facts you're owned
by a chinese company
people forget that for hundreds and
hundreds of years
countries operated based on
we want our country to win and we don't
want other countries to succeed
right it is only recently with the
internet and things like that
where this globalist mindset really kind
of took hold
but people i really have necessity and
safety and economic stability
were very nationalistic right if you
think back just
one generation there's an entire
generation of people that are 50 plus
years old
in this country and they absolutely
believe
in the american ideals the american
ethos they identify as americans
and they are anti anybody who's coming
for the american
way but that's 50 years plus right oh
they're over the age of 50 right
yeah but but again why is that changing
because it's becoming a much more global
uh world
is that a good thing i would argue i
would argue
global over here i would i would argue
i'm gonna i'm gonna flip around on the
table on both sides
so one would say that in our uh
desire to become a more globalist
society and economy
we have outsourced all of our
manufacturing and supply chains all the
stuff all over the world
and something like the global pandemic
immediately reminds us wait a second
resiliency in some cases is more
important than efficiency right
i did a whole podcast with uh chamoth
palopatia on this
and in that moment we realized we are
dependent on
china and mexico and all these other
countries to produce
goods like ppe to produce vaccines to
produce medicine all this kind of stuff
and if we do not get off of that
dependency and bring back manufacturing
and supply chains things to the united
states
we will be susceptible to that
dependency
now i'll flip back around onto the you
know holland before you flip
you know that reminds me of of like the
the manager who
outsources everything to their little um
underlings and then they themselves know
how to do nothing
and then when all their employees leave
they're like ah [ __ ] yeah that's exactly
what happens
but if i now go pro globalist i would
argue that
the innovation and the production of
humans
on a global basis has absolutely
exploded with things like the internet
and more people around the world with
different experiences speaking different
languages having more diversity all
working together
and so you get better solutions better
products better services whatever
and so what you're seeing right now is
not a competition between nationalism
and globalism that's not what's going on
here right
tiktok is going to try to claim that's
what's going on but at the end of the
day what you're seeing is you are seeing
a
company that has very real risks you
cannot
in any way shape or form defend that
they are not pulling more data than any
other company but privacy
and all of in data and all of that is
separate from
we don't like china it's not that's
that's the difference
if an american company was doing this
then
the american government would be able to
say hey what are you doing with the data
and they're going to oversight and all
this kind of stuff
the question is not people are not upset
with tick-tock because they're pulling
the data
what they're upset with is that that
company is owned
by a chinese company that products owned
by a chinese company
of which there are many people right i'm
not claiming that i think this but there
are many people who
who want to understand how influential
and how much control does the ccp
have over that chinese company because
if the chinese government is
getting the data of americans like your
cell phone
model the gps what you're doing what
other apps are on your phone all of
these things
that is very important information and
so this isn't a nationalist verse
globalist conversation
this is a country that is saying one of
our biggest
adversaries owns a business that is now
it has a product installed
on tens of millions of americans phones
what are you doing on our phones what
are you getting and how are you using
that information
i don't think those are crazy questions
but i also don't think that just because
the app
is chinese owned all of a sudden should
be banned right like there's nuance here
and we've got to get to the nuance
but all you're going to get is you're
going to get these titans of these
different companies arguing with each
other
all right great very there all right
that was my rant for the day
it's always a good rant okay um
do you know who ellen patrick off is
nope teach me something
okay so alan patrickoff is somewhat of a
legend in venture capital he's been
there basically since the beginning he
founded graycroft and apex partners
and he is 85 years old and now he says
i had another act in me and the energy
to do something else
this market is really fertile territory
he's talking about he's going to invest
he's raising a new fund and he's going
to invest in
aging americans or companies that cater
to aging americans all right so he's 85
years old he started graycroft which is
pretty big deal
uh apex partners i've never heard of uh
really no where have they been and
uh he's raising a 32 million dollar fund
to write checks of 250k to a million
dollars
for anything uh from services and
experiences for people over 60 to
financial security for retirees
uh as i've said many times before the us
government 40
of spending every year goes to people
over the age of 65.
uh so at the end of the day whether it's
public support or
private uh support there is a very large
percent of our population that is older
um and kind of the the baby boomers uh
and they need solutions so that's great
i don't know if necessarily a guy who's
85 years old is going to be the best
investor
to do it but no love that he's trying
there's a
guys go google i think it's in fortune
actually a really great profile on alan
uh from a few years ago did you write it
i did not write it
um but some of his investments over his
50-year career include america online
office depot apple audible axios and
wondering
speaking of apple interesting good
transition what's going on with apple
apple so oh don't get me wrong don't get
me on my second leg
no no no but apple is doing some sketchy
you know how yesterday i was like apple
get your [ __ ] together
yeah with the face mask well here's
another thing after airbnb and class
pass began selling virtual classes
because of the pandemic
apple tried to collect its commission on
the sales
so basically apple said it was entitled
to 30
of the sales uh from class pass
because the classes were sold on its
iphone
app virtually i see both sides of this
i really don't have a rant in the sense
of classpass and airbnb
are using apple devices to sell things
and they are also using the app store
and the rule is
if you sell things in the app store
apple gets 30 cut
so apple's saying you sold things in the
store give us a 30
class pass and airbnb are saying you're
taking advantage of us and you're
basically acting like a mafia and trying
to extort 30
from us well this is easy apple just
kick them off the
app store and say hey if you don't want
to pay by the rules
or if you don't want to play by the
rules and pay us our fees i thought then
you're out
i thought the drama was that apple
wasn't enforcing this across the board
no no no no no no so earlier you may
have heard us talking about
hey email an email product but what hey
was
doing was saying hey don't buy they're
saying don't
buy the product in the app store go to
this website
buy it on the website and then come back
and log in
and then you can use our product and
apple was stepping in and saying to the
creators of hey
we know you're trying to circumvent the
app store you excel to pay us
i'm perfectly fine if entrepreneurs can
figure out how to circumvent the rules
and not violate the
the rules then it's perfectly fine
audible does it netflix does it
uh hey email does it whatever but that's
not what airbnb
and classpath were doing airbnb and
class fast for
selling the actual product and having
the purchase happen in the app store
which would give apple the claim now ben
thompson has a great point where he says
apple basically thinks if you use an
iphone to conduct
commerce they should get a cut um hold
on a second but do we think that this is
a good
aside from whether they're right or
wrong is this a good look for apple
as tim cook goes into this anti-trust
hearing today
bullying small if i was tim cook what i
would say is
airbnb wouldn't be alive and neither
would class pass
if it wasn't for uh apple they wouldn't
have a business
right but does it give you the right to
bully them into submission over time no
no
you agreed you signed a contract with us
when you put your app in the app store
and so when you agreed to put your app
in the app store
you agreed to a contract so if anything
the people who are acting badly here
right or the class passes interviews who
don't want to pay
now again it's because they actually did
the the payment
if for some reason they had said hey you
know what we want to do this in the app
but you've got to go pay somewhere else
that's fine audible did this for
years netflix did it for years no
problem
yeah so i was just thinking if you were
at that hearing it'd be
so hilarious because you'd like argue
over like the tiniest little
nuances and like the details and the and
the semantics
like when we have an argument this is
how i would no this is how it would go
i'd be like you called me a bad mood
bear i am not a
bad mood bear i think i never said that
yes he did and then he would say
i didn't call you a bad bear
i said you were a bear in a bad mood no
no the way our arguments normally go is
i say you're acting stupid
and then you'll be like you called me
stupid i said no i didn't call you
stupid i said you're acting stupid
there's a difference but the record he's
never said you're acting stupid so now
i'm very
curious if you think i'm acting stupid
or you're being dumb it's like you
called me dumb like no i said you're
being dumb and so you're dumb i said
you're being
it's not making you look good for the
record no it's so completely fair you
somebody can act a certain way but not
be that way of course they can even the
nicest person in the world
like you could literally be the nicest
human in the world and be an [ __ ]
for 30 seconds to somebody but because
you were an [ __ ] it doesn't make you
an [ __ ] okay
car emotions what's up so now all these
cars
want to install actually some of them
already do have this technology cars are
thinking for themselves
yes in the car there is emotion
um there's ai that reads your emotions
while you're driving
and so automakers basically market the
systems as safety features if a car can
detect that a driver is
angry or looking at their phone
immediately before a crash
these companies reason the onboard ai
may be able to offer a warning the next
time it sees similar behavior
or if it can determine how a child is
positioned in the back seat the car
might deploy
airbags more effectively in the event of
a collision
i don't know this just seems like more
spying and a breach of privacy to me i
like it
really saves lives you're being dumb
but i'm not dumb but i'm being dumb no
it saves lives car accidents are still i
think there's like 80 000 people a year
who
die in car accidents or some some crazy
number like that and if there's a way to
one prevent distracted driving
uh and two also to do things like um
save children if the airbag gets
deployed whatever
you can do it in a very uh safe way in
terms of the data not being exposed okay
but you'd be okay
giving your facial data you won't even
come into the amazon store with me
i've never been in the ghost store
amazon go i ain't going in there you
ain't getting my face would be okay
giving your face to some automaker
yeah but i think that like so a great
example would be tesla if they did this
i would much rather give the data to
tesla and have it only reside on the
hardware of the car
how do you know how do you know they're
not going to sell it how do you know
what they're going to do
well that that would be part of the
analysis you'd have to do right is like
apple the reason why people are
comfortable giving apple the facial
recognition stuff
is not you yeah i don't give a mind
either but is uh because
it's it's local to your device like
apple servers never gets the actual
i don't trust it but my face is all over
the place you don't have you don't have
to trust it but i'm just saying like
that's the logic
all right are you ready for my joke is
this a good one yes
did you find this joke or did somebody
submit this
no but there's one that got submitted
that was really good and now i forgot it
all right well what is your joke
okay not funny what do you call it when
one cow
spies on another when one
cow spies on another yeah moving
no what a stakeout
a stakeout you cannot laugh at that
oh my god the people are gonna like this
they they get mine
what is one cow what is it how does
what do you call it when one cow spies
on another
a stakeout
it's funnier the third time around right
i see a small smile guys that's it for
lunch monday today well while she's
trying to get rich and i was just trying
to get our lunch money right
i hope you guys are finding the jokes
funny because i have yet to laugh
see you tomorrow yeah that's a smile
they're pretty funny
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest-bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends